♪
>> Tucker: WELL, A FEW
MONTHS AGO JAMES DEMUIR
LEARNED THE HARD WAY WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU QUESTION
WHILE WORKING AT GOOGLE, THE
WORLD'S MOST POWERFUL
COMPANY, DEMUIR PRIVATELY
CIRCULATED A PAPER
QUESTIONING HIS EMPLOYER'S
DIVERSITY POLICIES.
HE DIDN'T ATTACK ANYONE, HE
JUST QUESTIONED THE INTERNAL
LOGIC OF WHAT HE WAS BEING
CHARACTER AND THEN FIRED
HIM.
GOODMAN ARE SUING THAT
COMPANY THEY ARE SUING
GOOGLE OF SYSTEMIC BIAS
THEIR 161-PAGE LAWSUIT
EXPOSES A REMARKABLE AND
TERRIFYING CLIMATE AT
GOOGLE.
A PLACE WHERE BIASED,
HATEFUL, AND EVEN VIOLENT
POLITICAL RHETORIC IS
AGAINST THE RIGHT TARGETS.
THE SUIT CONTAINS DOCUMENTS
THAT SHOWS GOOGLERS MAINTAIN
EMPLOYEE BLACKLISTS.
THE FOLLOWING ON GOOGLE'S
INTERNAL NETWORKS FOR ALL
EMPLOYEES TO SEE:
BLOGGER CURTIS YARVIN KNOWN
LUNCH WITH AN EMPLOYEE.
ACCORDING TO THE SUIT HIS
ARRIVAL TRIGGERED A SILENT
ALARM AT GOOGLE.
SECURITY ARRIVED TO ESCORT
HIM OFF CAMPUS.
HIS MERE PRESENCE WAS
CONSIDERED UNACCEPTABLE.
AWARDED WITH BONUSES BY THE
COMPANY FOR PUBLICLY
DENOUNCING DEMUIR'S MEMO.
IN APRIL OF 2017, GOOGLE
MANAGER CHRIS BESELL ADVISED
EMPLOYEES IF THEY SPOKE AT
CONFERENCES THEY SHOULD DO
SO ONLY WHILE DEMANDING THAT
WHITE MALES FROM OTHER
COMPANIES BE KICKED OFF
PANELS IN FAVOR OF WOMEN OR
NONWHITE EMPLOYEES.
QUOTE:  YOU WILL FEEL PRETTY
DAMN SMUG ABOUT DOING IT
BESELL SAID.
GOOGLE H.R. SAID BESELL'S
ATTACKS ON THE BASIS OF RACE
AND GENDER SOMEHOW BROKE NO
BROUGHT TO LIGHT.
THE SUIT HAS MORE THAN 100
EXAMPLES OF EMPLOYEES AND
SUPPORTERS OUGHT TO BE FIRED
DEFENDING POLITICAL VIOLENCE
IMPLEMENTING GOAT THAT
SYSTEMS TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST WHITE PEOPLE AND MEN
TO THE BENEFIT OF OTHER
FAVORED GROUPS.
IT'S INTENT IS APPALLING.
DON'T KID YOURSELF, IT'S NOT
JUST HAPPENING AT GOOGLE.
LAST NIGHT DENNIS FINDLAY
WHO WAS AN EDITOR AT THE
BURLINGTON FREE PRESS WAS
FIRED BY THE MEDIA GIANT
GANNETT BECAUSE HE DARED TO
QUESTION A PROPOSAL THAT
WOULD ADD A THIRD GENDER
OPTION TO DRIVERS LICENSE IN
VERMONT.
NOW, IF YOU ARE
CONSERVATIVE, IT MIGHT BE
DIFFICULT TO GET YOUR HEAD
AROUND WHAT IS HAPPENING IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NO
LONGER THE MAIN THREAT TO
HAVE YOU GROWN UP THINKING
MAIN THREAT TO YOUR FREEDOM
AND YOU'RE PRIVACY.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T OWN
YOUR PRIVATE EMAILS.
GOOGLE DOES.
FEDERAL EMPLOYEES CAN'T BE
FIRED FOR THEIR POLITICAL
VIEWS, PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYEES ARE ALL THE TIME.
PUBLICLY COMMUNICATE YOUR
IDEAS.
TWITTER AND FACEBOOK CAN DO
THAT.
AND THEY DO DO IT ALL THE
TIME.
THOR WELLIAN FUTURE IS
INCREASINGLY THE PRESENT.
AND TECH BARRONS ARE
BECOMING OUR NEW TELL CZARS.
OPPOSITION TO OPPOSITION TO
CORPORATE POWER HAVE BEEN
THOROUGHLY CO-OPTED.
THEY ARE GETTING RICH FROM
IT.
JAMES DEMUIR HAS SEEN IT ALL
FROM THE INSIDE FIRSTHAND.
HE JOINS US NOW WITH HIS
LAWYER HARMID DILLON.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
>> HAPPY TO BE HERE.
>> Tucker: SO, JAMES, IN
READING THESE DOCUMENTS,
EXPRESSING YOUR VIEWS AND I
WANT TO RESTATE THE PIECE
THAT GOT YOU FIRED, YOU
WEREN'T ATTACKING ANYBODY,
YOU WERE RAISING QUESTIONS.
YOU GOT FIRED FOR THAT
GOOGLE SEEMED TO FEEL THE
NEED TO VILIFY YOU AFTER YOU
GOT FIRED TO DISCREDIT YOU
TO ATTACK YOUR CHARACTER AND
TONE COURAGE OTHERS TO DO
THE SAME.
THAT SEEMS STALINIST, WHY
DID THEY FEEL THE NEED TO DO
THAT, DO YOU THINK?
>> BECAUSE I ATTACKED THEIR
ORTHODOXY.
THEY REALLY NEED TO SEND A
MESSAGE TO OTHER EMPLOYEES
THAT NO, YOU CAN'T DO THIS,
YOU CAN'T QUESTION OUR
POLICIES.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
THEY CERTAINLY DID.
PAYING BONUSES TO PEOPLE WHO
DENOUNCED YOU LIKE A
REEDUCATION SYSTEM.
SO HARMID, IN THIS COMPLAINT
HAVE YOU EXAMPLE AFTER
EXAMPLE OF GOOGLE TARGETING
ILLEGAL.
IS IT?
>> IT IS ILLEGAL.
IT'S ILLEGAL UNDER FEDERAL
LAW.
IT'S ILLEGAL UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW.
WHAT A LOT OF LAWYERS AROUND
THE COUNTRY DON'T UNDERSTAND
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW WE HAVE
A UNIQUE LABOR CODE
PROVISION THAT MAKES IT
ILLEGAL TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST SOMEBODY ON THE
BASIS OF THEIR POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES OR THEIR
POLITICAL VIEWS.
AND THAT CAN ACTUALLY AFFECT
AND HAS AFFECTED WOMEN AT
GOOGLE.
TO BE CLEAR OUR LAWSUIT
ACTUALLY INCLUDES WOMEN AS
WELL IF THEY HAVE BEEN
CHARACTERISTICS.
>> Tucker: GOOGLE IS THE
MOST POWERFUL COMPANY IN THE
WORLD, THE MOST FAMOUS
COMPANY IN THE WORLD AND
THEY ARE DOING THIS OPENLY.
I MEAN, ON INTERNAL SERVERS.
THEY DON'T SEEM TO HAVE
WORRIED THEY ARE GOING TO
GET IN TROUBLE FOR VIOLATING
A PRETTY BASIC LAW.
WHY?
>> WELL, SO THERE ARE 700
BILLION-DOLLAR PLUS COMPANY.
THEY ARE UBIQUITOUS.
THEY HAVE VIRTUAL MONOPOLY
POWER OVER SEARCH ENGINES
AND THEY HAVE BEEN GETTING
AWAY WITH IT FOR A LONG
TIME.
YOU AND I AND OTHER
CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
ALARMED ABOUT WHAT WE READ
ABOUT GOOGLE BEING ABLE TO
SCAN G MAIL AND KEEP ALL OF
YOUR DATA.
THAT'S WHAT IS REALLY
TROUBLING ABOUT THIS.
THEY KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
YOU AND OWE OTHER HAND THEY
ARE USING THAT INFORMATION
AGAINST YOU.
WE HAVE SEEN THEM DO THIS IN
THEIR COMMERCIAL PRACTICES
AS WELL.
DEMON AT THISSIZATION OF
VIEWPOINTS THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IN ON YOUTUBE AND
OTHER PLACES.
I AM HEARING FROM PEOPLE
INSIDE THE COMPANY AND
PEOPLE WHO HAVE LEFT THE
COMPANY THAT THEIR
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
PROGRAMS FOR SEARCH ENGINES
SIMILARLY ARE APPLYING
POLITICAL BIASES AND FILTER
YOU AND I WOULDN'T KNOW IT
EVENTUALLY WE WILL FIND THEY
ARECOLOGY WHAT PEOPLE THINK.
OBVIOUSLY INSIDE THE COMPANY
CONTROLLING WHAT PEOPLE
THINK.
AND YOU KNOW, PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND ON SILICON VALLEY
THEY HAVE THESE CAMPUSES AND
YOU COME TO THE CAMPUS IN
THE MORNING.
THEY TAKE CARE OF YOUR DRY
CLEANING, ALL OF YOUR MEALS,
ENTERTAINMENT, EVERYTHING.
AND SO PEOPLE ARE IN THIS
LITTLE BUBBLE.
IT'S LIKE THE BRAVE NEW
WORLD SILICON VALLEY.
>> Tucker: THAT'S FINE.
BUT THE FACT THAT THEY ARE
CONTROLLING OUR POLITICAL
DIALOGUE AND THE WAY PEOPLE
EXPERIENCE REALITY AND
CONGRESS SITS THERE
PASSIVELY AS IF THEY HAVE NO
AUTHORITY IS CONTEMPTIBLE.
SO, JAMES, I WOULD
ENCOURAGE, BY THE WAY, OUR
VIEWERS TO GO ONLINE AND
READ WHAT YOU WROTE BECAUSE
IT'S HARDLY RADICAL, IT'S
ODDS WITH GOOGLE IS GOING TO
AFFECT YOUR FUTURE
EMPLOYMENT PROSPECTS?
AND MANY ELM EMPLOYERS HAVE
MADE IT CLEAR THAT THEY'RE
SPREADING THE MESSAGE ABOUT
NOT ONLY ME BUT ANYONE THAT
THEY HAVE DISCOVERED THAT
HAS CERTAIN VIEWPOINTS TO
BLACK BALL THEM OUT OF
CAREERS WITHIN SILICON
NOT TERRIFYING?
>> OH, I THINK IT IS.
MANY ARE
ARNY ARE
AREY ARE
AREMAARE
AREMANYE
AREMANY PEOPLE INSIDE THE
COMPANY.
THE THREAT IS NOT JUST
BLACKLISTS WITHIN GOOGLE BUT
BLACKLIST WITHIN THE ENTIRE
TECH COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES.
THAT'S HOW SCARY THIS IS.
>> Tucker: IF YOU ARE A
CONSERVATIVE AND YOU GREW UP
THINKING THAT THE FEDERAL
BUREAUCRACY WAS THE GREATEST
THREAT TO YOU, IT TAKES A
WHILE TO REALIZE, NO, IT'S
NOT, ACTUALLY, IT'S GOOGLE
AND THEY HAVE MORE POWER.
GOD SPEED TO YOU BOTH.
WE REALLY WISH YOU WELL AND